sur l'article premier
nous avons la ligne à deux qui nous
explique que l'Autorité de régulation
des communications de visuelles et
numérique
veillera ce que les contenus
pornographiques mis à disposition du
public par un service de communication
au public en ligne ne puisse pas être
accessible au mineur je comprends
parfaitement l'intention derrière cet
article qui est de nous expliquer que
l'arcome va être désormais l'autorité de
référence par rapport à la protection
des mineurs face au contenu
pornographique je m'interroge néanmoins
sur la pertinence de cette formulation
est-ce à l'arcom de veiller à ce que les
contenus pornographiques ne soient pas
accessibles aux mineurs ou est-ce au
fournisseur de contenu pornographiques
de veiller à ce que leur propre contenu
qu'ils mettent eux-mêmes sur Internet ne
soit pas accessible aux mineurs
est-ce qu'il ne vaudrait pas mieux une
formulation qui rappelle que l'arcome
est là pour s'assurer que les
fournisseurs de contenus pornographiques
s'assurent de leur obligation légale
plus que tout que dont nous expliquer
que l'arcom va veiller elle-même à ce
que ces contenus soient pas accessibles
aux mineurs
nous avons ensuite la ligne à 3
qui prévoit que l'arcome va édicter des
lignes directrices pour que les
plateformes puissent avoir comment
protéger les mineurs face à leur contenu
je tiens souligner le fait que cette
alinéa va parfaitement dans la ligne
stratégique de défense soutenue depuis
plusieurs mois par les plateformes
pornographiques que nous ont-elles dit
pornhub et compagnie nous dit on ne peut
pas se conformer à la loi on ne peut pas
se conformer à l'article de 127 24
puisque la loi n'est pas claire puisque
l'arcome et la CNIL ne nous disent pas
comment faire pour protéger les mineurs
face au contenu pornographique
et puisque la loi n'est pas claire nous
ne pouvons pas nous y conformer donc
nous considérons que c'est une loi
anticonstitutionnelle puisqu'elle ne
respecte pas la légalité des délices et
des persil de l'égalité des délices et
des peines et donc nous allons porter
cette affaire en question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité
ce à quoi je le rappelle la Cour de
cassation a estimé que la loi était
parfaitement claire et qu'à ce titre les
plateformes n'avaient pas besoin de
ligne directrice pour se conformer à la
loi et devait elle-même prendre les
mesures qui s'imposaient pour s'assurer
que leur contenu ne soit pas accessible
aux mineurs
donc j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que cette alinéa donne raison aux
plateformes en suggérant
qu'effectivement il est nécessaire que
les pouvoirs publics expliquent au
fournisseurs de contenu pornographiques
comment bien faire leur travail pour
s'assurer que les mineurs ne soient bien
danger